time now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week first up
could something as simple as a regular
dose of aspirin affect your risk for
certain kinds of cancer new research on
long-term aspirin use was presented at
the united european grat
gastroenterology conference this week
the study looked at over 600,000 people
from hong kong there were two groups one
used aspirin one did not
the aspirin users had been taking the
drug for an average of nearly eight
years participants were followed for up
to 14 years to measure the incidence of
cancer in each group joining us to
discuss the findings deep tease is CBS
News contributor dr. David agus doc what
they find it's pretty cool I mean so
this is one of many studies and so the
new study here it's an observational
study so dramatically lower risk in
esophageal cancer stomach cancer
pancreatic cancer and colon cancer in
the people who took the aspirin and also
slightly lower risk of prostate and
leukemia Wow it's a pretty dramatic you
down modulate inflammation from an
aspirin and Wow
cancer incidence goes down so shall we
all be popping aspirin I mean it is a
wonder drug 2,000 years old Hippocrates
said you take the bark of the willow
tree and chew it and pain the fever go
away but a 30% across-the-board
reduction in the death rate of cancer
from 81 milligrams of aspirin a day so
something to talk to your doctor Bell
you you have been you you're no stranger
to the aspirin world you've written
about this in the New York Times you're
an oncology I was 2400 years old you
don't look a day over 2,000 but you
don't in terms of aspirin in our general
sort of American vocabulary around its
health benefits what else are we missing
so you know we had done a study a cost
economic outcome studies showing that
like your 2036 if everybody who should
take an aspirin does 900,000 excess
people I love the word excess other
people are alive that would not have
been that we would have saved the
economy person 690 billion dollars in
savings that's pretty wild
that is that's substantial all right up
next with more talk of humans one day
colonizing other planets there's new
research on the effect of space travel
on the human brain a study published
this week in the
New England Journal of Medicine examined
the brains of more than 30 American
astronauts researchers conducted MRIs
before and after spaceflight to see if
the astronauts brains underwent any
structural changes this is what I really
want to hear what did they find
so spaced brain as we call it so when
you go up into space obviously gravity
goes down yeah and when that happens
fluid that normally is going down to the
ground goes up and so what you see is is
that areas where there was fluid build
in the brain the areas in between
sections of the brain the brain pushes
upwards the eyes push outwards there's
structural changes in the brain I is
right so these are people that have been
on the space station for months at a
time the longer you there the more
changes you've seen but we have to study
these as we talk about going to Mars and
other places do remember Mars is a four
to six months travel in weightlessness
we have to look at these changes if
we're actually gonna do something their
benefits to space brain asking for a
friend
Alex I know that look we just don't know
I mean we know the changes happen we
don't know if they're forever or if you
go back but the notion that the brain
has plasticity and can change depending
on your environment to me as a
fascinating observation seems like we
want to work out these changes before we
start sending people up no question but
the implications may be for stroke
recovery others if the brain has
plasticity and can change a couple
months in space what's it going to do
with disease that's really interesting
but because when the way you described
it initially I'm thinking this cannot be
a good thing right I mean I'm thinking
you come back with football brain
essentially I'm not sure it's the same
as a concussion but you're right these
are changes we don't know what it means
but certainly what we know as astronauts
have changes in their vision yeah
because you know all of a sudden it's
pushing out where those nerves and
they're not functioning the same and
when that brain changes we don't know
the implications so four to six months
travel to Mars Mars has one-third the
gravity we do and so you're gonna be
living there in this how do we do that
you know people in space they lose 1% of
their bone mass a month yikes
you know men and women as they get older
lose 1% a year so these are dramatic
changes that we got to learn in order if
we're gonna do this stain on
ferma all right finally tricking your
tastebuds high salt consumption can harm
your health it's one risk factor for
cardiovascular disease but what if you
need that flavor in your food a new
study found spices may be a good
substitute the research was done in
China and published in the journal
hypertension it found that the people
who enjoyed spicy foods tended to eat
less salt furthermore they also showed
showed more sensitivity to salt which
could contribute to how much they
consumed as if I needed another reason
to eat spicy food yeah it's pretty well
right I mean they we all need to
stimulate our space our space buds our
taste buds and so salt does it but spicy
foods can do the same and certainly it
seems to be a lot safer than having lots
of salt all right
sign me up with the Tabasco dr. David
agus thanks for your time doc you guys
privilege